[Music]
what's the greatest challenge of playing
chess 960 greatest challenge I think of
playing 960 is probably being wide
actually and I mean sort of that that's
a bit joking but also serious in that
there are quite a few positions where it
seems like one black plays symmetrically
it's very difficult for white to prove
anything get an advantage or not even
end up just flat-out worse so I think
playing with white is surprisingly
tricky because most of the time and
symmetrical setups there are clear ideas
and if you're white it's on you to come
up with something much more so than on
black but some say that you know you
should remember how to Castle because
that the rule rule of Castle changes
depending on the opening position it
just takes some time to get used to this
customink
it's just different compared to the to
the normal chess I mean it's just it's
just different for some reason after 15
moves or 20 moves position it's more or
less like regular chess so but the first
part is a bit more difficult pieces look
a bit weird at first and that's maybe
the hardest part because powerful and
said about the starting position chess
he said that the opening is the most
complicated part of the game because
there's the most pieces on the board
there's the most possibilities we don't
really think about it because we have
all this opening knowledge that helps us
get through it but if you took all that
away which is basically what you're
doing when you give us like a new
starting position we're completely on
our own and we realize that the opening
is the most complicated in most
difficult part of the game and getting
getting a decent position of the opening
is not easy at all especially if your
opponent is playing aggressively if he
knows what he's doing and if he's
putting pressure on you it's very easy
to get a bad position biggest challenge
has to be engaging to grips with what
the position demands I feel I'm not the
best in that sadly for me because I
think this is maybe the major thing that
sets apart sort of these is the best
room
nearly good in this format the faster
you come to grips with what the position
needs the better your results will be
just understanding the whole concept of
development and where you develop and
breaking the stereotypes that are
encoded in any player I think that's the
hardest thing I think it's it's it
challenges how creativity because we
used to play traditional chest and the
every position has its own specific
geometry so the weak spots the potential
evening squares that you should take
control of it as early as you can and
changing this geometry and also the way
the piece pieces are located which means
that they will have to look for
different routes to be developed with
middlegame
yeah it creates new challenge every time